so here's an interesting thought
experiment imagine one of uh your
friends comes up to you with a big smile
on his face and tells you that he just
got a brand new job and he's vague on
the specifics but he says it's a federal
government job and it pays six figures
and it didn't require any kind of uh
Bachelor or associate degree or a
physical fitness test or anything like
that but your friend does tell you that
as part of the application process he
had to complete a couple of computer
exams and then as the conversation goes
on your friend recounts a few of the
questions from one of those exams he
tells you the questions went something
like this quote would more classmates
remember you as humble or dominant what
age did you first start making money how
many high school sports did you
participate in now at this point you're
thinking to yourself that's a little bit
odd what kind of job would ask questions
like this it's all sounds kind of uh
dumb and and and unserious so your
friend reassures you that he had to
complete a second test as well and the
second test asked slightly more
challenging questions like what's the
difference between the numbers eight and
six and if you answered two then
congratulations you could also pass this
test and get this job now at this point
if you had to guess what job your friend
just landed what guess would you make
based on all the information provided
and knowing this is a government job
what would you think well you probably
make some obvious assumptions right away
you think at a minimum that whatever job
your friend is gunning for and the
federal government it can't be that
important and indeed there are a lot of
very unimportant jobs in the federal
government jobs that were made for
incompetent and unimpressive people I
mean the government kind of exists to
provide jobs for those sorts of people
so you might think well maybe it's one
of those jobs maybe your friend got a
gig in the you know the Department of
Education for example or the IRS that
would make sense but then imagine that
your friend informs you that he is not
working in some frivolous government
agency that contributes nothing of value
to humanity imagine he tells you that in
fact he applied to be an air traffic
controller and after just a few months
of training very soon he's probably
going to be directing planes with
hundreds of people on board now this may
be a hypothetical thought experiment but
it is very much grounded in reality I
didn't make up any of the test questions
I mentioned earlier they're all based on
real Air Traffic Control exams or pra
practice exams now 10 years ago this
little hypothetical scenario would have
been Unthinkable but everything changed
very quickly in 2013 when the Obama
Administration embarked on a plan to
diversify the ranks of air traffic
controllers Obama's FAA Chief at the
time announced that he intended to
transform the agency which includes Air
Traffic Control into a quote more
diverse workplace as part of that plan
air traffic controllers no longer needed
to take a more demanding cognitive
assessment before being hired instead
all they needed was a high school
diploma and the ability to speak English
and apparently to do very basic math
that like a third grade grer could
do all the tests were dumbed down to the
point of being absurd and
pointless now the result over the past
decade has been exactly what you would
expect even if you haven't heard about
this the number of air traffic
controllers who are not white men has
significantly increased while the number
of white men has decreased that was the
whole idea according to the FAA this is
what they tell us coincidentally so have
the number of near collisions involving
commercial airlines those have in
increased uh significantly according to
a database maintained by NASA which
relies on data self-reported by pilots
the number of near misses has more than
doubled over the past 10 years in just
the past year there have been more than
300 near misses involving commercial
airlines averaging more than five per
week and just to emphasize that point
again they diversify the
FAA and near misses immediately doubled
now correlation does not prove causation
but it can point towards it and in this
case there is a giant glowing sign
pointing in that direction of course
only a handful of these incidents
receive any major media attention so
it's easy to underestimate the scale of
the problem no matter what social media
platforms uh you frequent you don't
really hear a lot about a lot of this
and that's why in a moment I'm going to
go through some of the near misses that
have gotten very little coverage but
I'll start with an incident that did get
some attention from the national news
media because it helps put the broader
problem into some context so this
incident happened in July when air
traffic controllers put two aircraft in
allegion air passenger plane and a Gulf
Stream jet on a collision course shortly
after the Allegient plane had taken off
from Fort Lauderdale Hollywood
International Airport and uh here's how
that all played out watch the FAA and
NTSB are investigating a very close call
in the Skies over South Florida an
Allegent Airlines plane and a private
jet forced to take evasive action to
avoid a collision at 23,000 fet here's
Tom
Castello Alle legent air 485 had just
taken off from Fort Lauderdale headed
for Lexington Kentucky when it happened
the pilot forced to make a sudden
extreme climb 600 ft in seconds to avoid
another plane throwing flight attendants
to the floor and terrifying passengers
including Jerica fcker and her family
flying to Kentucky after a Caribbean
cruise it was honestly the scariest
thing I've ever been through it felt
like when you go on the top of a roller
coaster and you go straight down from
the highest point the FAA says it
happened when controllers put the
Allegient flight and a Gulf Stream
Business Jet on intersecting routes both
at 23,000 ft CL clim that's when both
planes collision avoidance warnings
known as tcast activated ordering the
allegian pilot to immediately climb and
the Gulf Stream pilot to descend if not
for TK these airplanes would have gotten
very very very close or have potentially
collided
now the report goes on to mention that
the Pilot's last minute evasive maneuver
was so extreme that it sent one flight
attendant to the hospital that's how
close these things got and if there's
anything reassuring In that clip
something that might make you feel a
little better if you like me plan on
boarding a plane in the near future it's
that the automated software called tcast
save the day this is a system that
relies on transponders that are
installed on all domestic aircraft and
as you heard it's capable of sounding an
alarm in the cockpit and directing
planes away from one another if there's
a risk of an imminent Collision it's a
fail safe for when air traffic
controllers mess up and command planes
to fly into one another but tcast isn't
perfect it certainly doesn't prevent all
midair collisions in 2002 two passenger
Jets collided over Germany because One
Pilot followed tcast while another
listened to the air traffic controller
who incidentally was later murdered by a
family member by of one of the
passengers that's a whole story in fact
just this year tcas failed to prevent a
midair collision at an International
Airport report in this country Houston
Hobby and fortunately and miraculously
nobody died as a result of that
Collision but it was very close to being
disastrous as you can imagine and that
incident illustrates the obvious which
is that a fail safe is just that it's a
fail safe it's not capable of solving
all potential problems it's not capable
of solving all midair collisions nor is
it designed to especially when planes
are are close to the ground and covering
a lot of ground very quickly in close
proximity to one another things can
happen too quickly for the system to
resp respond and those are the kinds of
incidents that are happening more and
more often I'm afraid to report Grand
Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University based in
Phoenix Arizona they are dedicated to
making education fit into your already
busy schedule which is why they offer
270 of their academic programs online
from scholarships to academic support
gcu's graduation team provides you with
the personal support you need to obtain
your goals gcu's online programs offer
you the freedom to earn your degree on
your own time from wherever you are GCU
is praise for its culture of community
giving an impact they integrate the free
market system and a welcoming Christian
worldview into all their academic
programs achieve your goals with a
personalized plan and a supportive team
behind you find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University private Christian
affordable visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
a month ago at Portland International
Airport for example in Alaska Airlines
jet uh turned directly into the path of
a departing Skywest airliner air traffic
controllers didn't notice this until the
planes were right on top of each other
and in that case the Alaska plane was
trying to land but it had to execute a
go-around because of high winds and
around the same time the air traffic
controller was telling a departing
Skywest plane to to turn right but for
some reason the Alaska pilot responds to
that command and he turns right into the
path of the Sky West plane the
controller completely misses this until
pretty much the last possible moment
radar data shows that the planes came
within 250 ft vertic ly and less than
2,000 ft horizontally which is very very
close in a plain terms and even closer
near Miss took place in August at San
Diego International Airport uh
controllers cleared a private plane to
land right on top of a Southwest plane
and they noticed their mistake just
before the private plane hit the
Southwest Jet on the runway the plane
got within 100 feet of the Southwest
passenger jet now there's no tcast
system that can prevent something like
that either if the visibility had been
worse um and if the controllers didn't
notice the problem there would have been
a collision and hundreds of people would
likely be dead you can go to YouTube and
find uh many Clips showing these near
misses most of them don't translate well
for the audio podcast listeners so we're
not going to play them here but I do
want to show you one for those who can
see the visuals and this may be the most
uh one of the most shocking recent
examples it's from JFK Airport in New
York City earlier this month which is
one of the busiest airports in the world
uh an American Airlines passenger jet
was lining up for its approach when air
traffic controllers told a small private
plane to line up for a parallel Runway
but the private plane didn't follow that
instruction instead it made a beline for
the same Runway the American Airlines
plane was going for at no point in this
process did controllers notice the
problem they also didn't notice that the
private planes didn't read back the
right clearance instead the only person
who noticed anything wrong were the
pilots of the American Airlines jet when
the private plane was already right on
top of them uh watch
this speed 235 turn left heading 260
right localizer left 2 6
2 American 28 main 179 6
191 28 179 6 191 178 and where's this
Pilatus going he's Landing the parallel
American 28 22 right he is right above
us American 22
2 American 2879
6 Speed 235 fling 180 appears you join
left fight heading 180 good speed
25 we're breaking off for American 28
he's right above us yeah we we were
watching on the scope uh it got a little
tight it got way too tight if we had
bailed out we would have
collided so if we hadn't bailed out we
would have collided is what's said there
and that's what the pilot of an American
Airlines Airbus said just a couple of
weeks ago at JFK airport there was
apparently no ke tcast instruction to
take evasive action if there had been
the pilots should have called it out but
they didn't there was certainly no ATC
warning and one of the pilots just
looked out of his window or maybe saw
something on the screen and realized the
plane was coming right for him and he
realized it just in time to save a lot
of lives now I could go on and on
there's the Southwest Airlines flight on
July 2nd which had to abort its landing
at New Orleans International Airport
because of a Delta plane that was taking
off from the same Runway uh the
passenger planes came within seconds of
hitting each other in that same month an
air American Airlines plane nearly
crashed into a Frontier Airlines jet on
takeoff because nobody including ground
controllers noticed that the nose of the
Frontier Airlines jet was jutting out
into the runway earlier this year in
February an air traffic controller
routed a Spirits Airline flight within
200 vertical feet and 700 horizontal
feet of a cargo plane so you get the
point now it's true that we can't blame
this dramatic rise of near misses solely
on diversity and Equity e efforts you
know single variable explanations are
rarely sufficient especially when you
have a complex issue like this for one
thing when Ronald Reagan fired more than
10,000 air traffic controllers who went
on strike back in the 80s in violation
of federal law a bunch of new
controllers needed to be hired and many
of those controllers recently hit
retirement age all all at the same time
which creates a staffing Crunch and
that's also part of the issue but that
Staffing crunch was foreseeable it's
been obvious that it would happen since
Reagan fired the controllers more than
four decades ago the problem is that
instead of providing incentives for
competent people to become air traffic
controllers Say by raising the salary
providing more training offering better
hours you know those sorts of things the
government chose to do what it always
does it drastically lowered the
standards in the name of equity and the
body Administration is still proud of
this right now on the faa's website
you'll find this line quote the mission
of the FAA involves securing the Skies
of a diverse Nation it only makes sense
that the workforce responsible for that
mission reflects the nation that it
serves actually no that doesn't make
sense the job of the FAA and air traffic
control is preventing catastrophic
accidents where a lot of people die
doesn't matter what the workforce looks
like everybody knows this because deep
down everybody knows that diversity
doesn't actually matter everybody knows
that and that's why no passenger on a
plane has ever cared in the slightest
about the racial makeup of the guys in
the cockpit or the ones on the ground
directing the plane just like nobody's
ever cared about the diversity of fire
departments when they're trapped in a
burning building nobody's ever cared
about diversity among brain surgeons
when they have tumor that needs to be
removed when it comes down to it when it
really
matters diversity doesn't matter and we
all know it but unfortunately that's
what the FAA has been focused on lately
just a year ago the FAA launched yet
another initiative to diversify the
ranks of air traffic controllers meaning
to hire people based on qualities other
than competence uh the FAA calls this
the batc campaign the agency says in a
press release that quote building on
last year's successful campaign to
receive more applications from women and
other underrepresented groups the FAA
will again work with diverse
organizations host Instagram live
conversations and work with social media
influencers so that's what the FAA is
working on right now as we have this
catastrophic rise in near misses uh at
airports and in the skies they're
working on getting more women and
underrepresented groups by partnering
with Instagram influencers so they want
to get people you know into the towers
Air Traffic Control they want to get the
the sorts of people who are listening to
Instagram
influencers so this is a a disaster
waiting to happen that much is clear
what's not clear is whether we'll be
getting a Workforce that's capable of
preventing two jetliners full of
passengers from colliding with one
another while they're each going in
excess of 500 Miles hour and that is
alarming to say the least because every
single week we're discovering that the
existing crop of air traffic controllers
is barely capable of doing that now keep
in mind this is this is all happening
even as Airlines also begin their own
quest to add more Equity to their ranks
it was only a couple years ago that
United Airlines pledged to diversify uh
its pilots and many other airlines have
followed suit so very soon we will have
diverse air traffic controllers
directing diverse airline
pilots who have all been hired for
reasons other than their skill and
competence while thousands of lives hang
in the balance and inevitably many are
lost in the process because that's where
this will
go now you often hear Aviation experts
say that nothing ever gets fixed until a
lot of people die which is not a thought
that will help cure your anxiety about
flying but it's true it's what they say
and it's been true throughout the
history of Aviation planes didn't have
wind shear detectors until commercial
airliners started crashing in bad
weather just shy of the runway tcast
wasn't mandatory until there were a lot
of midair collisions Pilots didn't have
to De I until an air Florida plane nose
dived into into the bomic after sitting
for too long on the tarmac on a snowy
day what this means is that if history
is any guide soon enough we may finally
start to get some solutions to the air
traffic control debacle we're seeing
right now all over the country from
Portland to San Diego to New Orleans to
New York to pretty much every other
major metropolitan area in the country
and that's because as problem atic as it
may be for the B administration's Equity
agenda we're closer than we've been in
more than a decade to a disaster of
truly historic proportions like it is
going to happen and probably soon and
when it does a lot of people will
die and then and only then when it's too
late will anything be done about the
problem thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast